the united nations intergovernmental
panel on climate change has released
another apocalyptic report about the
perils of the sun monster which it now
describes as a quote code red for
humanity
the news could not come at a worse time
when humanity is already on the brink of
extinction from the wuhan cough and to
mark the occasion
hundreds of the world's most prominent
climate activists and covid
communicators just flew to martha's
vineyard many of them on private jets to
dance around masculists at barack
obama's 60th birthday party
do as they say
not as they do i'm michael knowles this
is the michael knowles show
[Music]
welcome back to the show my favorite
comment yesterday night yes it was like
a week ago i don't know what it was from
solomon risely who says roses are red
maybe they're blue in biden's america
nothing is true that is such
a good simple
observation because that's what barack
obama is showing us that is what all
these climate hypocrites are showing us
that is what the covid cops are showing
us and when you want to protect yourself
from all those prying eyes i would
strongly recommend you check out
expressvpn i do not go online anymore
without a vpn on my computer and on my
phone and on any other device that i use
i can say with full confidence that
expressvpn is the best vpn on the market
here's why expressvpn does not log your
activity online lots of cheap or free
vpns make money by selling your data to
advertisers well if they're going to do
that what's the point of using a vpn vpn
expressvpn does not do that they even
developed a technology trusted server
that makes their vpn servers incapable
of storing any data at all speed
expressvpn now uses lightweight it's a
new vpn protocol they engineered to make
user speeds faster than ever it's always
blazing fast lets me stream videos in hd
quality with zero buffering lets me
upload really big files as well it's not
just me saying this cnet the verge many
other tech journals rate expressvpn the
number one vpn in the world protect
yourself with the vpn that i use and
trust use my link expressvpn.com
michael today get an extra three months
free on a one year package that's
expressvpn.com
michael visit expressvpn.com michael to
learn more
none
of the things that these people
want you to believe
are among the things that they believe
these on i'm talking about the climate
i'm talking about covet i'm talking
about all of it
they purport to believe something they
insist that you believe something
whether it's that the sun monster is
going to destroy the world or kovit's
going to kill everybody or we you know
we everyone needs to triple quadruple
mass with 17 jabs that's the only way
we're going to be safe
they do not believe that and the way
that i know that they do not believe
that is that they do not behave as
though that were true
barack obama just had his 60th birthday
party amid not just the global pandemic
but amid the surge forget about slow the
spread stop the
flatten the curve find a cure no now
we're surging so we got to be super
duper careful go back to all the
restrictions unless you're barack obama
barack obama holds his 60th birthday
party he got a lot of backlash because
he initially planned to invite about 500
guests and about 200 staff
and then
when he got the backlash his spokesman
said it would only be close friends and
family it turned out that was a complete
lie there were hundreds and hundreds of
people there because some photos leaked
then the photos all went back down but
the internet is forever so barack obama
was just having a grand old time
with everybody there's video of him
dancing around maskless you don't see a
single mask in the entire place not the
musicians not the guests certainly not
barack obama not the staff you just none
none
anywhere
really weird really weird videos going
around from this event so glad they
finally went up obviously none of these
people are worried about the wuflu
they're not worried they want you to be
really worried about it but they
themselves are not worried about it
this also shows that there are two sets
of rules there are one sets of rules
there there is one set of rules for the
elite and then there is one set of rules
for everybody else one new york times
reporter actually defended the party and
said that the obamas only invaded
sophisticated vaccinated people
unlike you you filthy disgusting
idiot you rube
you unsophisticated
monster
there are the sophisticated vaccinated
people and then there's the rest but
but
we were also told
that the virus is spreading among the
vaccinated people we were also told that
the viral load especially of the indian
delta variant that the vaccinated people
are carrying is similar to the viral
load that unvaccinated people are
carrying so if the idea is we've got to
stop the spread then it doesn't matter
if you're vaccinated or not frankly it
doesn't matter if you've even taken the
negative covid test
i was just on a flight
i came back it's very good to be back
with you i missed you terribly i i was
in france for my friend's wedding and
fortunately the new covid rules where
you've got to show your past to the
gestapo and show a proof of vaccination
that actually had not gone into effect
yet that didn't go into effect until
yesterday as i was flying back to
america the land of the free for now
but i i was on the flight and i ju i
finally realized how nobody actually
believes any of this stuff with kovid
and the it's the scariest thing ever and
we've all got a lock down we all have to
wear the masks because they make a big
point of telling you on the airlines
and in the airports
that you have to wear the mask that it
doesn't matter if you're vaccinated it
doesn't matter that you had to show a
negative covid test you actually had to
show a negative covet test to get on the
plane back to the united states doesn't
matter all of these people
none of whom have kovit according to
very recent tests still have to wear the
mask the whole time that's how dangerous
covid is
okay totally
blows obama's cover on his party but
that's how dangerous cove it is that you
cannot you can't take it down i want to
like gucci goo my little baby no you
can't take the mask down for that
until they serve you a drink
or until they serve you a hamburger
or until and i kid you not they actually
did this on the flight they came over
and served a nice delicious warm
chocolate chip cookie
it was great i'm glad they served the
cookie
covid is so dangerous that we have to
muzzle ourselves for a year and a half
it can never take it down even if your
triple quadruple vaccinated with 17
negative coved tests
unless there's a warm delicious cookie
in which case you can of course not if
it were that big a deal they would just
nix the cookie but they're not mixing
the cookie because none of them believe
any of this
nonsense
i
i've noticed something else when i was
in france which is and this is so
shameful this is so embarrassing for me
to say for my own country
the french people are more sane about
the coronavirus than we are
they are i'm not talking about the
governments the french government is
just as crazy as the u.s government if
not crazier and we'll get to that in
just a little bit but i just mean the
french people
the french people are just not as insane
about this they do you walk into a place
you don't have a mask on it's not a big
deal
you get it you get into a car a as you
need me to put the mask on oh no that is
okay miss you i'm vaccinated it's fine
the whole point of the vaccine is that
then you do not catch the virus it is
fine miss you they're just they're just
cooler about it's not
as intense
a political issue there among the
french people
among the
government officials that's that's quite
a different matter but it really when
you travel abroad it really makes you
you're sure you learn about some other
culture but it really makes you see your
own culture much more clearly i've
always found this to be true when i
would go to italy sometimes as a kid i'd
think man
i really miss america they're really
efficient they really know how to run
things over there oh man you go you
travel to other places you really see
your country more clearly
and
i think when we get a clear look at our
country right now probably we're not
going to be so happy ann applebaum a
liberal journalist
just
tweeted out a few days ago in response
to tucker carlson's trip to hungary
she said in orbonz hungary victor orban
the right-wing leader in hungary and
orban's hungary 90 plus of the media are
controlled by the ruling party
businesses are physically and legally
harassed if they don't tow the party
line or if someone wants them cheap
elections are manipulated party leaders
are mysteriously rich
and then she added a model for fox news
you know it's like a dig in that's what
fox news wants
does she not
see what she wrote
90 of the media controlled by the ruling
party business is physically and legally
harassed if they don't tell the party
line elections manipulated party leaders
mysteriously rich gee what other country
does that sound like anne
gee oh wow victor orban's hungry that
sounds like a crazy dystopia i've never
heard of oh wait a second that perfectly
describes our own country but she can't
see it
or she's choosing not to see it because
she is within that dominant
establishment regime
it is coming here i'm glad that i got to
see
france right before
the insane lockdown rules went into
effect because
our leaders here our ruling party which
our ruling class includes the democratic
party the leaders of the institutions
meaning
the big corporations the mainstream
media
high education low education big tech
all of it they are working in concert
to force us all
to toe the line on the masks on the
vaccine on the tests on the everything
even nancy pelosi who had previously
pelosi and joe biden had been fairly
modest about what they said were going
to be the covid regulations when when
they were asked even just a few months
ago
are there going to be mandates are there
going to be all these things they said
no the american people they aren't ready
for that no i don't think so
now they are signaling and it's not just
it's not just the democratic party it's
their proxies in the private sector as
well now they are signaling that the
france-style full-on gestapo show me
your papers lockdown is going to be
coming to the united states
really makes you want to stop relying on
these people for
for your livelihood it really makes you
want to do things for yourself when you
want to fix your car yourself
i would strongly recommend you check out
rock auto rockauto.com just makes it
easier
to get the auto parts that you need it's
so much easier than walking into that
store and then you get the questions hey
uh what what kind of car do you have i
don't know i got a i got a ford yeah
okay what type of ford i a ford f-150 oh
yeah okay and what what year i don't
know i was like 2018 2019. yeah okay and
what color and what this and what that
and the gt and the x3 and the what i
just i don't know
i don't know and then the irony of
course is that the person in the
brick-and-mortar goes into the back of
the store they don't have the parts
there's too many parts they don't have
them they go online probably to
rockawater.com they order the part they
charge you twice as much you wait two
weeks why would you do that
that would be madness don't do that
rockauto.com always has the lowest
prices available no gimmicks they've
been serving auto parts customers online
for 20 years
they
do do not change the prices for pros and
do-it-yourselfers head on over to
rockauto.com right now see all the parts
available for your car or truck and then
write knowles k-n-o-w-l-e-s
in there how did you hear about us box
so they know that we sent you nancy
pelosi april 29 2021 said
in response to a question over whether
or not they will mandate vaccines for
americans they said we
cannot require that someone be
vaccinated so here's the thing we are we
cannot require someone to be vaccinated
that's just not what we can do
it is a matter of privacy to know who is
or who isn't
i can't go to the capitol physician and
say give me the names of people who
aren't vaccinated so i can go encourage
them to or make it known to others to
encourage them to be vaccinated uh so we
can't we can't do that
okay so in this case nancy pelosi is
speaking specifically about her house
members we cannot
require that people get vaccinated
how long ago was that just a few months
ago now nancy pelosi
threatening to do the very thing that
she said it was not possible to do
several house democrats have called for
the capital physician to institute a
vaccine or test mandate for members and
staff you've previously said that
members can't be compelled to get
vaccinated because it's a matter of
privacy and you can't know who is and
isn't vaccinated do you still hold that
belief and do you see some merit in a
vaccine or test mandate well you just
only gave part of my statement what i
said was that we
are guided and have to be guided by the
guidance of the
capital physician
he has made those
uh contentions and when
the weighing the equities take us to a
different place i'm sure he will tell us
now in a matter of maybe days or weeks
the full approval will be given uh to
the vaccines and that i think will make
a difference in terms of of
what we can do
now it should go without saying that
that what nancy pelosi just said she
said is not what she actually said she
she did not say
that the
capital physician is going to be the one
to determine whether or not she can get
this information from members in demand
they'd be vaccinated what she said was
it is wrong we are not able to it is a
matter of privacy that we cannot go to
the capital physician and ask these
sorts of things
then she just sort of flips that around
says yes we can do it she
obviously never believed what she said
in the first place namely that she
couldn't force people to get vaccinated
she was simply biding her time
she was simply exercising the political
power she felt that she could exercise
at the time she could exercise it and
now she's going to exercise more
this is why of course none of these
people have any credibility the in the
media in the public health establishment
and the elected democratic party they
don't have any credibility whatsoever
you should not believe a word that they
say they have i don't think they had a
lot of credibility before the covet
stuff but during the covid stuff they
have squandered what little they had
they're liars they don't like you they
want to rule over you and they do rule
over you and they will get you to comply
if you do not resist and they might get
you to comply even if you do resist the
crux here of the matter in pelosi's new
argument is the full approval to the
vaccine don't forget
all of these people thus far who have
pressured you to get the vaccine
are pressuring you to get an
experimental drug
the vaccine the multiple experimental
drugs the pfizer moderna johnson and
johnson
and any of the others that are that have
been in development
the reason that
it does not it that it is an
experimental drug is it does not have a
full fda approval it has an emergency
use authorization
i'm not saying anything about the
effectiveness of the vaccine far be it
for me i'm just pointing out that the
emergency youth authorization gives
special liability protections for the
makers of this vaccine for the people
pushing this sort of vaccine and what
she's saying now is yeah when it was an
emergency youth use authorization it was
tough to mandate that everyone get it
but once it's got full fda approval then
then we will be able to force everyone
to get it maxine waters
one of the more honest members of
congress in her she doesn't even often
hide her radicalism or her explicit
calls for violence against her political
opponents maxine waters is just saying
flat out we're moving toward a vaccine
mandate do you think that there should
be a a vaccine mandate i think we're
moving toward a mandate this is very
dangerous and i think we're finding that
people are dying and younger people are
being attacked by this virus and so i
think we're going to have to be very
careful we're going to have to be
dedicated to the proposition uh that
we're going to get everybody vaccinated
and that
we're going to stop what i think could
be
a lot of deaths that would take place
without doing it well certainly health
care workers should be vaccinated it is
unbelievable that we had health care
workers
that were not vaccinated and so that is
a must in the congress of the united
states i think we should also have the
mandate that you must be vaccinated that
you must wear the mask we must social
distance because again you know the
delta varant is a killer
yeah she doesn't believe that none of
these people believe any of that they're
not behaving as if they believe that
when kovid was in the height of its
surge and at the apparent height of its
virulence all of these people supported
blm rioting in the streets burning down
the country rubbing shoulder to shoulder
they just don't believe it they
angelo coda villa made this point
angelo codavilla from the claremont
institute made this point about
political correctness and i mentioned it
in my book speechless which is that
political correctness is very often less
about
the substance of what they want to
change it's very it's often less about
the specific words or the specific
behaviors and it's much more often about
the imposition
itself and that is what
this is about here that is what the
mandates and
maxine waters and nancy pelosi and the
rest of them that's what they're talking
about
they
are showing that they have the right
to impose these things upon you and
moreover
getting back to barack obama's birthday
party that they have the right to
violate the rules whenever they want
without consequence without consequence
whatsoever
there is a video that went viral
yesterday and i had just left paris i
just left the very place that this video
was taken of people sitting at outdoor
cafes many of which i frequented last
week without being harassed by anyone
demanding my papers
where the police now show up
and demand to see a vaccine card
you can see the cops walking up to i
don't know if they're tourists or
or french citizens themselves
police walking through the streets
and they have to produce the digital
pass
on their phones
the digital pass makes it
very very easy to enforce this sort of
thing because
it's not as though you can fake a
digital pass and it'd be probably much
more difficult depending on on the
enforcement measures
it's not as though you have any excuses
to why you wouldn't have your digital
pass everyone's sitting out there on
their phone so the cop just comes over
and says okay show me your pass
this is why it's going to be very
important that people like pelosi and
waters and the rest of them the american
left and a lot of the squishes on the
right too are going to be pushing for
this sort of thing
the only difference the only difference
between these two countries that is
preventing the the united states ruling
regime from instituting this stuff is
that we have a more robust system of
federalism so in france they don't have
this idea that the various states can
push back against the federal government
the states have specific rights that the
federal government can intrude on and
the people have certain rights that
actually can't be intruded on either
that that does not really exist in
france here it does and so it will be
entirely incumbent upon the governors to
hold out against this kind of stuff to
not turn over vaccine information to the
federal government to not create digital
passes like already exist in new york
right the
liberal states are already moving toward
the digital passes the conservative
states are not they have to hold the
line on that as well
that is some dystopian
stuff
that's being pushed by liberal regimes
around the world i mean the parisians
are furious about this there were
hundreds of thousands of people out in
the streets when when this regulation
was first proposed by the leader of
france macron
so people the people much more normal
but but it doesn't really matter because
the ruling regime has the power one way
that they're going to be able to push
this by the way
is not even through the heavy hand of
government one way that they're going to
be able to push this that's really going
to confuse conservatives especially the
kind of conservatives who have just been
carrying water for the regime for the
last 20 years the kind of just talking
point right winger is that they're going
to do it through private companies so
right now united airlines is going to
mandate the vaccine for all employees
this is the first move for a domestic
u.s airline
they're going to mandate that 67 000
people
get the covid vaccination
they will do this
and demand it five weeks after the
vaccines are fully approved by
government officials or by october 25th
whichever date comes first according to
reports so even if by october 25th the
vaccine is still an experimental drug
without fda approval united airlines is
going to force that to happen
this is the point of donald trump's
lawsuit against big tech when donald
trump says big tech is violating my
first amendment rights all of the
sophisticated people all of the really
smart genius lawyers they laughed at him
and they said a private gov a private
entity cannot infringe on your first
amendment rights it's only the
government that can infringe on your
first amendment rights but the point of
the lawsuit is that the government is
using these so-called private companies
as proxies to enforce its will and by
the way biden admitted that it was doing
as much that's what's going on here with
the vaccination regime the liberal
establishment is relying on
quote-unquote private companies to do
its bidding now i think the important
thing for conservatives to remember here
by the way
is that the issue is not whether or not
a company has a right
to mandate a vaccine it's not whether or
not even a school district or something
has the right to mandate a vaccine lots
of companies and private entities and
school districts already do mandate
certain vaccines so i think if
conservatives make the argument that
they have no right you know my body my
choice or something which is by the way
not not something that we believe in we
do not believe my body my choice we're
pro-life right that we think that there
are other considerations here as well
what we have to focus on is the
prudential question
the wisdom of mandating this vaccine
this vaccine which is still an
experimental drug for a virus that
nobody is all that seriously concerned
about including and most especially the
liberal elites who are making the
biggest ruckus about it
you know who's not
a liberal elite
the people who run my pillow that's who
you know how much i love all of the my
pillow products they're a great
conservative patriotic company but even
if they were run by communists i would
still shop from them that's how good
their products are my pillow is now
changing the game with their six-piece
towel set this set is made with usa
cotton makes it extremely absorbent yet
still provides that soft feel that you
look for in a towel the set comes with
two bath two hand towels and two
washcloths typically retailing for
109.99 for a limited time you can get
this set for the low price of 39.99
that's over 60 in savings
always remember all my pillow products
come with a 60-day money-back guarantee
you have nothing to lose they come in a
variety of colors and sizes they are the
best towels go check them out today head
on over
mypillow.com click on the radial
listener square use promo code daily
wire there you will find not only this
amazing offer but also deep discounts on
all my pillow products including my
pillow mattress top or my pillow towel
sets and so much more you can also call
1-800-951-7163 use the promo code daily
wire that is mypillow.com make sure you
use promo code dailywire great time to
order the authoritarian moment that's
ben's new book it's my future campaign
slogan it's a great book to order right
after you order my book speechless you
can get both at amazon barnes and noble
or any other major bookseller go get
your copy right now leave a five star
review if you liked what you read and
also
if you sign up now as a daily wire
member with code vip you'll get 25 off
your new membership be automatically
entered for a chance to win a trip for
two to the daily wire studios in
nashville to see candace live both the
person and the show not only will you
meet candace herself you'll be getting
an inside look at her studio and front
row seats to watch her show live that's
dailywire.com
subscribe with code vip 25 off so you
can automatically be entered for a
chance to win the vip experience or if
you're already an all-access daily wire
member you can now purchase tickets to
her show in nashville tennessee head on
over to dailywire.com tickets today to
pick up yours we'll be right back with a
lot more
vaccine mandates are not only coming
from governments around the world
they're coming potentially from our own
government as well but joe biden i think
just undercut his case for the vaccine
mandate
because
according to president joe biden
107
of americans have already been
vaccinated
i said again and again this is a
pandemic of the unvaccinated
so we have to get more people vaccinated
i said
well over what's the number again i
remind myself 350 million americans have
already been vaccinated
they're doing fine
good news buddy that's great i'm so glad
we're doing 350 americans in a country
of 328 million people are doing fine
maybe
what joe biden is admitting here is that
there are a lot of illegal aliens in the
country maybe there are many more than
even you and i knew about maybe he has
secret numbers or maybe he has
absolutely no idea what he's talking
about he's flubbing the messaging which
he has done from the beginning of this
because by the way
even as of five minutes ago the argument
has not been that this is a pandemic of
the unvaccinated we've been told that
the vaccinated are
transmitting the virus
and are carrying the virus in similar
viral loads as the unvaccinated people
but the argument has been that the
vaccinated face less severe consequences
they face a far
lesser risk of death and yet we're then
told at the same time that we've all
still got a mask up we've all still got
to lock ourselves down even if you are
vaccinated
very confusing messaging but it's not
the most confusing messaging that the
white house has put out on kovid this
week
because they have relied once again
on
a social media influencer this one i had
never heard of him before
i i sort of hope i never hear of him
again but i did watch this video
so that you don't have to you know
delve through all the piles and piles of
horrific viral videos around i watch
this
this is from benny drama
he played the role of a white house
intern filmed in the white house with
members of the white house staff
including jensaki to convince all the
unvaccinated people to go get the
vaccines
one sec democracy's calling see you
daddy bye hi my name is cooper and this
is a day in my life as a white house
intern
[Music]
we did a joke
hey everyone vogue
usually i start off with a big coffee
sorry they're like really strict in here
hey jenny i booked you a nail
appointment love yeah i didn't tell you
to do that it's called initiative
hi white house is a scooper um i don't
think so
oh it doesn't matter
this is actually the entrance to the
west wing this is so fun and it's really
prestigious hey potus is olivia rodrigo
still here no
we've come a long way in our fight
against this virus we've vaccinated 160
million americans are you getting this
all down don't worry queen it's all
right here
cooper
sorry miss jen and jen don't forget to
have fun
spirit fingers mama we need to get shots
in the arms of every single american i'm
heading to a haircut comment if you want
me to make more of these
i don't even know exactly what i just
watched i don't know what parts of it
were supposed to be funny or persuasive
but i do know this
according to
the democratic party the people who are
not getting vaccinated
are
conservative right-wing christian
bible-thumping republicans in the red
states right that's what that's what
we're told from the liberal
establishment it turns out the group of
people
least likely to be getting vaccinated
are actually
black americans who i think their
vaccination rates right now are like 28
or something like that black americans
overwhelmingly vote for the democratic
party but because the democrats don't
want to acknowledge that it's actually
largely a group of their own voters that
are not getting vaccinated they try to
blame it on conservative christian
right-wing republicans in the red states
many of whom also don't want to get
vaccinated either
and the white house decided
that the best way to persuade
conservative right-wing christian
bible-thumping voters in the red states
and black voters as well
is with an officiously
flamboyantly gay gender bending
zoomer or millennial tick-tock
influencer
that's what's going to do it right that
nothing
nothing those bible thumpers or those
sort of vaccine hesitant black americans
love more right famously historically
nothing nothing they all love more than
very very officiously
sexually
revolutionary gender-bending young white
liberals right
[Music]
but no of course not of course not that
the video won't persuade anybody and it
doesn't matter they don't care because
the white house doesn't actually need to
persuade anybody because the entire
thing is about scoring political points
and none of them are actually that
worried because if they were that
worried
they would actually put someone on the
video that might be able to persuade
either the right wing evangelicals or
the black voters in the cities but they
don't because it's not a big deal if
they actually care they wouldn't serve
the warm cookie on the airline okay they
just make you wear your masks all the
time because the virus is so super duper
deadly it's the deadliest thing in the
history of the world
or
they'll say take your masks off eat the
cookie it's fine but you can't
simultaneously
say both
things
speaking of our representatives
you know i'm kind of down on our
representatives these days but there was
one representative who really came to
the national attention while i was in
france and so i i didn't want to miss
out on acknowledging her wonderful
performance to i don't even know to
pronounce her name tamyra mensah stock i
don't you know i don't watch the
olympics i don't keep up with these
sports but i loved her this gal won
she
is a wrestler she won she gave her
victory speech and she said that she
just loves america and she is so proud
to represent it
of course i surprise myself it's by the
grace of god i'm able to even move my
feet like i just leave it in his hands
and i pray that all the practice that
the hell that my freaking coaches put me
through pays off and every single time
it does and i get better and better and
it's so weird that there is no cap to
the limit that i can do and i'm i'm
excited to see what
what i have next last question for you
that american flag around your shoulders
looks pretty good how does that feel to
represent your country like this it
feels amazing
i love representing the us i freaking
love living there i love it and i'm so
happy i get to represent
u-s-a
well said congratulations enjoy that
gold and we'll see you out there on the
podium okay thank you i'll try not to
cry but no promises
love her awesome this is great stuff
it's uh
very important that all the athletes do
this if you do not love your country if
you're not happy to represent your
country then don't go to the olympics
the point of the olympics is that we
send our athletes to go represent the
country as i've made abundantly clear i
don't i don't tend to watch the olympics
but i do care about my country and even
those of us who don't watch all these
various games and are kind of skeptical
of the whole thing
we still have a right to as we send our
athletes overseas to represent us we
have some right to expect that our
athletes will love our country this gal
obviously does and it is important
especially because she's a black woman i
know that conservatives don't like to
play identity politics and conservatives
are now being accused of playing
identity politics because she's a black
woman it actually does matter because
the prevailing narrative that we're all
being told is that black people can't
love america because america was founded
on
oppressing black people that's the new
1619 narrative and so if you're black
the only authentic reaction you can have
to the country is one of contempt and
disdain and hatred and it's just not
true
there have been plenty of black
americans who have loved their country
that's been true from the very beginning
of the country that's true up to the
present and it is important to show that
it is very important to show because we
are
susceptible to these kinds of
circumstances to these
aesthetics to these uh trends you know
all of us really are if we're if we are
told that all the smart people hate
america then
if we hope to be smart we're going to be
tempted to hate america
if we are told that all the black people
hate america then if you are black you
are going to be more inclined to hate
america because you're because you are
simply living within this mental prism
that that is what you have to do if you
look a certain way or if you aspire to
be a certain thing or whatever and so
it's very important to show people that
the smart people can like their country
too that black people can like their
country too that people from the coasts
can like their country too that new
yorkers and angelinos and chicagoans can
like their kind the people in academia
can like their country too the people
wherever in the media right all over the
place where we are told
that it is not
that if you are a certain way you look a
certain way you think a certain way
got to get rid of that got to get rid of
that speaking of women
there's a story out of california now a
female inmate in california is now
pregnant after
women's prisons were forced to accept
male prisoners who claim to be women
so this has been happening for
a few years now there's been a push
uh for women's prisons to accept dudes
and the phrase that's often used is
biological males they have to accept
biological males i hate this phrase
people should stop saying this phrase
the phrase biological male is a it's
itself a creation of political
correctness it's not a reaction against
political correctness it is a product of
it because the implication of the phrase
biological males is that there's some
other kind of male you know a
psychological male or a spiritual male
or no there's just men there's just men
and women okay and there's no special
caveats or categories here
so the women's prisons now have to
accept men
and this is according to a report from
the blaze
that uh women a liberal women's
organization the women's liberation
front has reported that at least one
woman has become pregnant following
california's law that lets men enter the
women's prison here's what the women's
liberation front a very left-wing
organization says quote
women incarcerated in california's
largest women's prison are describing
the conditions as a nightmare's worst
nightmare after the introduction of new
pregnancy resources in the central
california women's facility medical
clinics the new resources are a tacit
admission by officials that women should
expect to be raped when housed in prison
with men where all sex is considered
non-consensual by default within the
system
which brings me to compassion
compassion
when i was at this uh wedding i was
chatting with
a
very lovely gal she was so nice i think
probably
she represents what the majority of
americans feel politically which is they
don't have especially strong political
views they just want to be like nice and
on the good side and be nice to people
and not mean to people and the issue of
transgenderism came up
and she said well i just i just think
it's really we shouldn't be mean to
people we should be nice and my point as
conservatives often make is that i don't
think it's nice to lie to people i don't
think it's nice to encourage some people
to live in delusion i don't think that's
respectful at all i think that's
actually cruel i don't think that the
truth is cruel i don't think that lies
will set you free actually i think it's
the opposite
the argument for letting men into the
women's prison
is that it's compassionate these poor
men they think that they're women so we
should let them into the women's prison
well is it compassionate to the women
who are now
being exposed to
some of these men could have committed
sex crimes
there's no there's no rule often barring
men from who have committed sex crimes
from coming in now this woman is
pregnant where's the where's the
compassion where is all of that
compassion compassion can be pretty
pretty misguided and but the left is
very good at using this language of
compassion and niceness and i do think
conservatives need to get better at that
because if conservatives can't then it
doesn't matter how
strong our arguments from biology or
psychology or philosophy or theology are
people aren't going to want to associate
with conservatives speaking of creepy
sex stuff by the way
andrew cuomo i go away for one week and
it looks like
the governor of new york is on the ropes
again
not because he killed thousands of
elderly new yorkers in nursing homes but
instead because he winked at his
secretary some more there's a report
from the new york attorney general the
report says
andy cuomo ran his hand across the
stomach of a female state trooper
assigned to his detail
she says
this move left her feeling completely
violated
he did that only one month after he
signed a 2019 law strengthening
protections for sexual harassment in the
workplace according to the report from
the state attorney general you'll notice
during the i'll get back to andrew cuomo
in a second but i just want to broaden
it out for a bit
you'll notice that among the the metoo
people and the time's up and all the
really strong this is what a feminist
looks like men who are left-wing and all
that
during the metoo movement virtually
every
big shot who went down
was a leftist feminist stopped the
sexual harassment this is what a
feminist looks like sort of guy
but they just don't believe it
they just didn't believe it
i think this was a little different than
having a standard and falling short of
it i think these guys were rank
hypocrites i don't think they believe it
i think they want other people to play
by a set of rules that they don't have
to play by i think it's the same thing
as obama i think it's the same thing as
the
covet and climate alarmists all the
climate alarmists who fly on private
jets to go talk about how important it
is not to fly on private jets
i think all of that is coming out and
unfortunately we can point to it and we
can show how little credibility they
have but they still have the power
maybe andrew cuomo will go down over
this latest round of sex stuff maybe
maybe not he's a pretty tough guy it
looks like this is harder his his
right-hand man actually a right-hand
woman his top aide was a woman she just
resigned right now it looks like new
york democrats are looking at a possible
replacement for cuomo i
look this looks even
worse than the last time that cuomo was
allegedly on the ropes the only thing
i'll say is the guy's a fighter the guy
is a survivor he's got nine lives so he
might be able to survive this too
regardless though his reputation is
really really tarnished my only issue in
all of this sure andrew cuomo might be a
pig he might he might
pinch any any lady who walks by he might
be absolutely uh you know reprobate
but that's what that's what we're going
to take him down for
that's what we care about that's all we
care about now
this it's so
frivolous
this guy
killed thousands of elderly new yorkers
through his covet policies
all the while bragging about how great
his coveted policies were all the while
publishing a book and winning an emmy
for how great his coveted policies were
and emmy for goodness sakes
meanwhile he's lying to federal and
misleading federal investigators
covering up the nursing home deaths and
we get him on winking it as secretary
how frivolous how frivolous all of this
is
but it's that's because we are not as
serious a country as we once were
because we we can't really discuss moral
issues in a sophisticated way as we once
did now
really the only way to take someone down
is through the most lurid sort of
scandals
which actually brings up an issue for
joe biden because if andrew cuomo goes
down over the creepy sex stuff
this could theoretically pose a problem
to joe biden
jensaki was just asked this at the white
house
joe biden has been accused by a former
staffer of sexually
violating her and so if he's entitled to
a presumption of innocence that's all
well and good but should there not be an
investigation of joe biden just as there
was an investigation of andrew cuomo an
investigation that turned out to be
quite warranted
in a follow-up to the report on governor
of homosexual harassment a lot of men in
politics have been accused of sexual
harassment president biden was accused
by female secret service agents of
skinny dipping in front of them
offending them according to over
washington post reporter ronald kessler
who is an author as well
his former senate aide tara reed accused
him of sexual assault
the washington post and the new york
times have published multiple accounts
of women who objected to the way
president biden touched them
should there be an independent
investigation of allegations into the
president as there was into governor
cuomo well first i would say
the president has been clear and
outspoken about the importance of women
being respected and having their voices
heard and being allowed to tell their
stories and people treating them with
respect that has long been his policy
continues to be his policy uh that those
were that was heavily litigated during
the campaign i understand you're eager
to come back to it uh but i don't have
anything further other than to repeat
that he has called for uh the governor
to resign
so she completely punts on the question
she says oh yeah i mean look it's an
excellent question i'm glad the reporter
asked it because certainly if this were
really about standards if this were
about a real rule then yes there should
be an investigation into joe biden
and if tara reid turns out to be true
forget about even believe all women just
if the allegation is is supported which
it is way more supported than anything
anyone ever said about brett kavanaugh
if that is
shown to be likely then it would cause a
big problem for joe biden but the thing
is if cuomo goes down
he's not going to go down because
he
sexually harassed his secretary he's
going to go down because the democrats
want him out because he's now too weak
and he's probably too weak much more
because of the covet scandal than
because of the sex scandal and the thing
is they don't want joe biden out yet and
so he's just gonna survive it because
they've got the power and you do not
which brings me to one more creepy viral
tick-tock video
these sex scandals seem very strange
today
because
we've all gotten used to all
sorts of sexual scandals that aren't
even scandalous anymore there was a tick
tock that went viral of some person on
the left
describing
regular old
heterosexuality you know just a man and
a woman love each other very much and
have babies as a breeding kink oh i'm
super straight i'm only attracted to
women who can bear me children babe
that's called a breeding kink
and it's not a sexuality so a breeding
kink is this individual is making fun of
people who hold a traditional sexual
ethic who think that in the words of the
great philosopher nor macdonald sex is a
filthy shameful thing that obviously is
only meant for procreation and that you
should maybe get married before you have
sex and that when you have sex you
should be open to the possibility of
life and have children have a really
good life
and what this person is saying is no
that's a breeding kink some people have
a kink for
whips and chains some people have a kink
for
threesomes and some people have a king
for breeding but it's all just kinks
right it's all just kind of weird quirks
of sex
and
what that implies is that there's no
standard what that implies is that that
no sort of sexual behavior is any better
or worse than any other sort of sexual
behavior
right it's all just relative it's all
just what you want it's all about your
desires now this creates a problem in
the metoo era because
their sexual standards will come in they
will be enforced in some way and so now
people have to explain why
certain sort of
ugly sexual encounters are fine but the
exact same sorts of sexual encounters
when they're undertaken by different
people or in different circumstances are
not fine and it's just it's very very
confusing we've been told that women are
totally liberated they ought to be able
to relate to sex in exactly the same way
as men but then when women come to
regret sex as in the case of high
profile cases like marilyn manson or
other other uh
partners and lovers of these these
various men they say well yes it was
consensual but he still abused me and i
didn't like it men and women are
different but they're not different and
it's all very confusing because we don't
have any sort of standard
when we don't have principles when we
don't have a standard when we don't have
a vision for society then all we are
left with is the arbitrary power of the
elites of the capital physician of dr
fauci of the head of the un climate
change panel we'll get we'll get to it a
little bit more or maybe we won't it
doesn't matter it's the same story
different day the u.n though is saying
that the world is going to end from the
sun monster this is really a code red
they've been saying this for decades at
this point and even beyond the climate
change issue we've been told by the
scientific geniuses since the 1970s that
the world's going to end if we don't
give them all of the power well that is
what we are going to do inevitably if we
do not have a positive vision to push
against and to to offer as an
alternative to the arbitrary capricious
rule of the genius elites who by the way
don't even believe the stuff that
they're trying to sell us see you
tomorrow i'm michael knowles this is the
michael knowles show
[Music]
the michael knowles show is produced by
ben davies executive producer jeremy
borin our technical director is austin
stevens supervising producer mathis
glover production manager pavel vadovsky
editor and associate producer danny
d'amico associate producer justine
turley audio mixer mike coromina and
hair and makeup by nika geneva michael
knowles show is a daily wire production
copyright daily wire 2021.
john bickley here daily wire
editor-in-chief wake up every morning
with our new show morning wire on
today's episode pressure ramps up on
governor cuomo to resign the aclu is
suing the biden administration and fake
vaccination cards are on the rise join
us and get the facts first on the news
you need to know with our show
morningwire